we have some really big and really
exciting news today as you all saw in
the title Hailee Steinfeld could be the
new Hawkeye in the MCU how's it going
everybody it's Warren and this is really
big and really exciting and important
news that could affect not only the
present MCU but the future of the MCU as
well this news really does affect the
future of the MCU more than you think it
would but don't worry I'm going to break
down everything you need to know about
this new report that Hailee Steinfeld is
going to be playing Cate Bishop the new
Hawkeye and how she could go on to lead
the New Avengers team first don't forget
to subscribe to my channel so you can
enter my giveaway for a chance to win an
Xbox one or a ps4 and don't forget to
check out the link in the description to
enter a giveaway for your chance to win
a Nintendo switch so this news comes
from an exclusive by variety and
according to Variety they have
exclusively learned that Marvel and
Disney have offered the role of Kate
Bishop in the upcoming Hawkeye series -
Hailee Steinfeld again huge news when
phase 4 was revealed they revealed that
we are getting an upcoming Hawkeye
series and we have learned that the
Hawkeye show is going to be about
Hawkeye Clint Barton training Kate
Bishop to be the new Hawkeye now this
does happen in the comics Kate Bishop
takes on the mantle of Hawkeye so it is
really cool to get to be able to see a
Kate Bishop Hawkeye in the MCU but
what's really exciting is that Kate
Bishop actually goes on to be a major
part of the Young Avengers and she goes
on to lead the West Coast Avengers and
Hailee Steinfeld is a really great pick
to play Kate Bishop in the MCU she's
done really well in all of the movies
that she's been a part of so far and she
did an excellent job in bumblebee
now of course Marvel and Disney offering
her the role of Kate Bishop for the
Hawkeye series isn't just for the
Hawkeye series because we know that
Marvel and Disney don't really do that
we have a Marvel Cinematic Universe that
builds over the years and Kevin Feige
gave the president of Marvel Studios has
already confirmed that the Disney Plus
shows will bleed into the MCU and we
will see some characters from the shows
in the movies so she's really not just
signing on to play Kate bishop in the
Hawkeye series she's signing on to play
Kate bishop in the MCU for years
because remember the MCU is rebuilding
we had the nfinity saga and that came to
an end now the new characters are going
to be introduced and built up over time
and Kate Bishop is one of those
characters and like I said we know that
Marvel is developing a young Avengers
and Kate Bishop will definitely go on to
be a part of the Young Avengers and then
eventually a new Avengers team so this
is super exciting news that they offer
to Hailee Steinfeld the role of Kate
Bishop I personally hope that she takes
it I think she would do an excellent job
but let me know what do you all think do
you like this casting choice do you hope
Hayley takes the role of Kate Bishop and
plays her in the MCU or do you think
that Marvel and Disney should get
another actress be sure to let me know
in the comments down below and again
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
if you'd like a chance to win an Xbox
one or ps4 like the video and comment
with your favorite superhero or villain
check out the link in the description
down below for your chance to win a
Nintendo switch and as always thank you
all so much for watching will fall off